okay we have the gustavson gambit
from bulgaria i don't know what the
[Music]
what the good stuffs on gambit is though
if anybody can explain i would be happy
to hear
is it this one no that's the wing gambit
but we'll go for it anyway
oh b6
that is sorry to say
that is a bit wimpy
there's no reason not to take that pawn
there's no reason
so now we'll instead play a
grand prix attack with
without the ones bishop d6 looks a bit
weird i got e5 with tempo then
knight e4 and
it's worth noticing that c5 is a lot is
a lot weaker
than it would have been with uh
without um without the exchange of the
b-pawns
so no now i'm going bishop 83 with a
little trap in mind
let's see if my opponent sees it
sometimes i explain my traps in advance
but sometimes i don't
now knight b4 okay
we'll go c3 my trap was in case of
knight e7 i would go knight d6
check and then knight g5 and he cannot
protect f7
so we'll go for some here we'll go for
something more
precise instead knight d6
knight g5 seems like a decent enough
pre-move
and knight h6 i'm gonna go queen h5
and bring a lot of hurt to my opponent's
position
f6 well no reason not to jump in
queen eight is not possible
[Music]
and
the advertised hurt looks
like it will happen quite imminently
okay we go ef6 both of the knights are
protected at the moment
gf6 only move king f6 queen g5 would
have been made
and now now i think we just start
collecting
way too many of my opponent's pieces are
hanging
so we take
um yeah we take that
that bishop then we take a rook
um 1986 is still hanging
[Music]
queen g7
means the knight is still hanging so
i'll take it
and the pawn is now hanging so i'll take
that
and let's see if we can
wrap this up with a nice little trap now
with queen g2
i would have had bishop h5 followed by
queen
rook g1 now i'll have to settle for
something
a little more precise check ph
king g8 is the only move queen c8 queen
f8
and i'll take d7 and we continue
harvesting
maybe i'll actually go with b1 here
trying to get rook b8 and quick mates
seems like almost no worries a move
and it it increases the chance
of the game being over soon which is
good
because then i get to play more games
against
more premium members
97 doesn't seem to help
i just go rp8 and queen e7
and queen star
okay yeah next time dude gustavson
gambit
accept the gambit you'll be better off